will we ascend our consciousness or will
we revert back to the dark ages there
are eight billion of us on the planet
that now have unprecedented levels of
Technology and ability to communicate
with each other will we leverage that
technology to increase our consciousness
or will we use that technology to
destroy each other we are going to have
to learn how to live in a civilized way
with these melting pots of culture
across the world the technology that we
now have can help us raise our
consciousness faster than ever we have
to step up and take leadership roles in
this ascension of consciousness in the
healing of ourselves and the healing of
each other in this healing is no more
about the old technologies of healing
the ones that enable profiteering off of
industries like the healthcare industry
but rather ones that are of a completely
new era an essence look at your
timelines look at your ancestors look at
who brought you into this world and the
circumstances that they had persevered
through in order to do so
how big of a synchronicity of a gift is
it that they went through the challenges
that they went through in order to get
you into these exact circumstances that
you have now and how can you maximize
unleashing that gift that they work so
hard to bring you into so that you could
unlock it and unleash it into the world
at its maximum potential the universe
has specifically brought us to this
point this pinnacle point of challenge
to see if we will have the ability to
persevere through this complex climactic
point or if we will revert back to the
dark ages and have to try again become a
teacher of higher consciousness become a
teacher of unity of oneness think of
yourselves as doctors of peace healing
ourselves healing each other and
catalyzing peace and harmony with each
other with nature
passing judgment and passing prejudice
does not lead us towards love peace and
harmony we are being pushed to this
question are we ready to extend to new
levels of consciousness or will we
revert back to the dark ages and need to
start again and we're not being told how
to do this this is the ultimate
adventure of our collective
consciousness to see if we can persevere
through this most difficult of
challenges this point of higher
consciousness there's no conflict
there's only love there's true peace and
harmony we came to Planet Earth we fell
from grace in order to achieve this
greatest challenge planet Earth has
duality this is one of the only ways
that humans can learn when we get so
miserable that we have to change our
lives we set up situations to learn and
then we choose to grow up and deal with
it or run away from it when will I find
peace and harmony when you're buried in
the ground you came to this planet to
live through this dichotomy to
experience the resistance the duality
the angst and the challenge and rise to
the occasion of solving some of our
greatest civilizational challenges this
is a big petri dish there are different
paint strokes being made different notes
being played in the symphony the strokes
on the canvas and you get
to choose what contribution you make of
bringing forth your own gifts get things
done that challenge you rise to the
highest consciousness on this soul
journey of yours
we are fractals of God coming here to
learn to create to experience the
illusion of separation from that unity
to launch ourselves into these bodies
and learn more and then bring it back to
that central source we are all being
watched can we ascend our consciousness
or will we revert back to the dark ages
planet Earth is a hologram not a reality
we create relativity and reality by our
level of consciousness so we can say
this is my reality but it's not a truth
even gravity is a relative truth it's
universal to us on this planet or the
molecular composition of water being
relative to us on this planet just like
your truth is relative to you into your
consciousness so there is no one truth
there are eight billion truths and we
can still learn to love and live
together through that is potentially
source central source a single truth how
do we convince people that acts of
violence don't serve us so if their
truth is to commit that act of violence
how do we convince them that that
doesn't serve the planet does the soul
the spirit come here to learn these
lessons
how much do our parents need to back off
and let the child experience their own
truths relative to their consciousness
source making this universe as a
hologram in this all being an illusion
it not being the oneness the soul or the
spirit the thing that separates us from
the oneness but what is the purpose of
that solar spirit then it is so that it
can come for this unique adventure of
learning and then bring that information
back to the central oneness there are no
words English in the Mandarin no words
that can describe oneness that can
describe unity so one of my challenges
is how do I create the words and the
story to bring us closer together to
that central source to help us become a
pinnacle civilization where we're all
unleashing our unique gifts in harmony
with nature so how can we retain as much
signal as possible from our communion
with the central source and then
distribute that disseminate those
stories and those words to other people
to get them inspired to commune with
their own journeys with source and
unlock their own gifts into the world
how can we heal how can we get through
this wisdom race as effectively as
possible those are the main pillars of
my ethos and I hope for those that are
watching for you to know that about our
channel and what we aim to do a
simulation this is it right here so join
us in this adventure go and commune more
deeply
with the divine yourselves and unleash
your gifts more into the world have more
conversations with your friends your
families co-workers and people online
about these topics and support us so we
can keep doing this work you can find
all of our links in the bio below to our
patreon or cryptocurrency our PayPal
links are below
you can design cool merch and get paid
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders and the
organizations in your communities and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world we got this
lets ascend consciousness versus going
back to the dark ages